das könnte eine ganz neue chance für
unsere suche nach außerirdischen leben
seien die rede ist von einer ganz neu
aufgespürten klasse lebensfreundliche
planeten britische fachleute sind sich
sicher dass diese exoplaneten die
vollständig mit wasser bedeckt sind gute
bedingungen für die entwicklung und
existenz außerirdischen lebens bieten
werden wir hier endlich fündig klick zum
science in future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
die wahrscheinlichkeit für leben hier
sollte sie größer sein als auf allen
anderen planeten die rede ist von einer
neu aufgespürten klasse am planeten
außerhalb des sonnensystems diese
exoplaneten sind schwerer und größer als
die erde sind vollständig mit wasser
bedeckt und weisen eine dichte
wasserstoff atmosphäre auf diese klasse
von exoplaneten nennen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
heißen kombiniert aus den beiden
englischen wörtern hydrogen für
wasserstoff und ocean für ozean und
diese könnten sehr viel häufiger
vorkommen als felsplaneten mit flüssigem
wasser schreibt ein britisches
forschungsteam jetzt in der aktuellen
und super spannende studie wie genau
kann man sich diese wasserwelten also
vorstellen und warum sind sich die
fachleute so sicher dass diese
speziellen exoplaneten bewohnt sind die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen gibt es hier bei pixum seit ca
möglicherweise waren wir bei unserer
intensiven suche nach außerirdischem
leben auf einer falschen fährte
fachleute weltweit hatten vor allem
erdähnliche gesteinsplaneten wie sie
also planeten die unserem heimatplaneten
der erde sehr ähnlich sind wichtig
hierbei die sogenannten habitablen zone
gemeint ist damit die abstands region in
der ein planet einen stern umkreisen
muss damit gemäßigte temperatur
möglicherweise die existenz von
flüssigem wasser erlauben denn flüssiges
wasser gilt zumindest bei dem leben das
wir auf der erde kennen als
grundvoraussetzung dafür das leben
überhaupt existieren kann doch britische
fachleute sind nun auf einer neuen spur
sie haben massereiche wasserwelten
aufgespürt die gute chancen auf
außerirdisches leben bieten wie das
forschungsteam jetzt in ein aktuellen
studie berichtet diese haitianischen
welten wie sie in der fachwelt
bezeichnet werden besitzen einen
globalen ozean und eine
wasserstoffreichen atmosphäre
ein konkretes beispiel für solch eine
wasserwelt könnte die 124 lichtjahre
entfernte supererde k2 18b sein sie ist
etwa doppelt so groß wie die erde und
besitzt die achtfache masse bereits im
vergangenen jahr hatte der britische
astronom nico motto sudan von der
university of cambridge mit seinem team
diese super erde genauer ins visier
genommen denn schon damals stand die
frage im raum ob diese supererde einen
lebensfreundlichen ozean beherbergt in
der vergangenheit hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in der gashülle wassermoleküle
nachweisen können eine sensation und
eine echte premiere
die super er der k 28 zb war somit
nämlich der erste exo planeten in der
habitablen zone bei dem astronomie teams
wassermoleküle in der gashülle finden
konnten dies deutet darauf hin dass sich
da unter wasser und möglicherweise sogar
ein lebens frontier ozean befinden
könnte doch das war bis dahin nur eine
vermutung denn lange stand die frage im
raum ob die gashülle dieser super erde
möglicherweise zu dick ist falls ja
würde der gewaltige druck die existenz
von flüssigem wasser nämlich unmöglich
machen dazu der wissenschaftler nico
sudan um die aussichten für die
habilitiert dieses planeten einschätzen
zu können ist es wichtig seinen inneren
aufbau und die atmosphärischen
bedingungen des planeten zu kennen mit
der hilfe einer simulation kam das
astronomie team damals zu einem
eindeutigen ergebnis auch wenn der
exoplaneten eine große masse aufweist
ist es keineswegs ausgeschlossen dass
ein flüssiger ozean auf ihm existiert
die modelle zeigen dass dies sogar bei
mehreren kombinationen von kern masse
und dicke der gashülle denkbar ist und
das ist eine spektakuläre erkenntnis das
forschungsteam schreibt dazu dass das
potenzial für habitablen bedingungen
nicht notwendigerweise auf erdähnliche
gesteinsplaneten beschränkt ist auf
deutlich mehr himmelskörpern als bislang
angenommen könnte also aus also das
leben möglich sein und genau an diese
sensationelle erkenntnis schließt das
britische forschungsteam jetzt an dazu
heißt es und zur der aktuellen studie
ozeanische welten können bis zu 2,6 er
trat in groß sein und eine masse von
zehn erdmassen erreichen es ist
faszinierend dass lebensfreundliche
bedingungen sogar auf exoplaneten
existieren können die so anders sind als
die erde laut der britischen astronomen
und astronomen zeichnen sich solche
ozeanischen planeten durch ihren aufbau
aus der aus vier schichten besteht sein
inneres besteht aus einem eisenkern der
rund zehn prozent seiner masse ausmacht
dann ein gesteins mantel eine
wasserschicht und eine atmosphäre die
sehr wasserstoff reicht ist und genau
diese atmosphäre ist entscheidend denn
sie ist der große unterschied zwischen
den normalen wasserwelten und dem
haitianischen planeten und dieser hohe
anteil an wasserstoff in der gashülle
der haitianischen planeten spielt eine
entscheidende rolle denn das sorgt dafür
dass solche reinen wasserwelten kein
problem mit dem kohlenstoffkreislauf
bekommen denn am grund ihrer ozeanen
kann sich im extremfall eine art
hochdruck eis bilden und das sediment
als kohlenstoff puffer fehlt dann es ist
einfach nicht zugängliches ist quasi
versiegelt schwankungen des
atmosphärischen co2 können somit nicht
oder nur schlecht abgefangen werden im
schlimmsten fall droht dann ein enormer
treibhauseffekt oder aber eine vereisung
genau diese risiken minimiert der
wasserstoff in der gashülle vor allem
wenn er im hohen maße vorhanden ist so
wie bei den ozeanischen planeten doch
auch der ozean dieser exoplaneten
übernimmt eine entscheidende rolle denn
er wirkt als druck- und klima puffer das
sorgt für habitablen bedingungen nämlich
konkret dafür dass der atmosphärischen
druck absinkt und somit potenzielles
leben möglich sein könnte die britischen
astronomen astronomen halten es für
ziemlich wahrscheinlich dass diese
ozeanischen planeten leben beherbergen
könnten das leiten sie unter anderem von
den extremen bedingungen ab die in den
ozean auf der erde herrschen selbst an
thermalquellen im tiefen ozean konnten
bereits in der vergangenheit
mikroorganismen aufgespürt werden diese
halten hohen wasserdruck und
temperaturen von mehr als
sich grad celsius aus und nicht nur das
auf der erde wurden wirklich zahlreiche
wirklich denkbar lebens fand ihre orte
aufgespürt wo es trotz extremer kälte
oder hitze von organismen nur so wimmelt
zum beispiel bei 122 grad celsius in
heißen quellen und auch das andere
extrem ist möglich selbst hunderte meter
unter dem antarktisgletscher eis ist
leben möglich erst im vergangenen jahr
hatte ein israelisches forschungsteam
eine entdeckung gemacht die unser
verständnis von leben verändert denn
bislang hatten fachleute die regel
aufgestellt das ohne sauerstoff kann
leben existieren kann doch der quallen
artige parasit mit der bezeichnung henne
goya salmi nicola der vor allem in
sachsen vorkommt belehrt uns eines
besseren denn er benötigt keinen
sauerstoff zum überleben er atmet nicht
und ist nicht vom sauerstoff abhängig
das war wirklich eine komplett neue
erkenntnis denn bislang kannte man diese
fähigkeit nur von einigen einzeller die
in extrem sauerstoffarmen umgebungen
existieren können egal also ob gedruckt
große hitze dunkelheit oder wenig bis
gar kein sauerstoff die irdische
wasserwelt zeigt eindrücklich dass
marine organismen auch mit extremen
bedingungen zurechtkommen und damit sind
wir wieder beim außerirdischen leben
denn das leben das sie auf der erde
unter extrembedingungen aufgespürt
werden konnte spricht auch für die
möglichkeit von leben an sehr
unwirtlichen orten im weltall zum
beispiel auf den haitianischen planeten
nach ansicht des britischen
forschungsteams könnte sich das leben
hier komplett im wasser abspielen ja
ähnlich vorstellbar also wie das leben
das zu beginn der evolution auf der erde
existiert hatte die berechnungen des
forschungsteams aus cambridge legen nah
dass die ozeane auf den haitianischen
planeten bei temperaturen von minus 33
plus 150 grad potenziell
lebensfreundlich sein können die so
genannten dunklen haitianischen planeten
könnten demnach sogar noch bei einer
globalen mitteltemperatur von bis zu 230
grad potenziell habit abel seit wie das
forschungsteam schreibt gemeint sind
damit wasserwelten in sogenannter
gebundene rotation die zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass sie ihrem stern immer
die gleiche seite zu kehren nur ihren
nachtseite wäre damit lebensfreundlich
und nicht aber ihre ab seite die zu heiß
für leben wäre das fazit der fachleute
ist eindeutig haitianische welten
eröffnen uns damit eine ganz neue chance
für die suche nach leben auf anderen
planeten ein grund dafür ist dass die
habitablen zone dieser haitianischen
welten viel größer ist als bei stans
planeten die um den selben stern kreisen
denn die innen grenze der habitablen
zone kann deutlich näher am stern liegen
unter anderem weil der ozean der
ozeanischen welten gefährliche
strahlungs ausbrüche des sterns abfangen
kann auf bis zu 900 tausend kilometer
könnte sich demnach ein haitianischer
planet seinem stern nähern und trotzdem
noch lebensfreundlich seien ein weiterer
vorteil über den sich die fachwelt freut
die planeten sind deutlich größer als er
zwillinge und so bekommen wir die chance
ihre atmosphäre und oberfläche besser
mit teleskopen untersuchen zu können
natürlich vor allem um nach bio
signaturen für leben zu suchen wie
beispielsweise sauerstoff ozon methan
oder stickoxide in der gashülle oder
auch nach molekülen wie methyl chlorid
oder die mittel sulfit auf erdähnlichen
exoplaneten können wir derzeit die
spektren solcher moleküle noch nicht
nachweisen unserer teleskope sind wir
sagen einfach noch nicht gut genug dafür
die ozeanischen exoplaneten dagegen
bieten sich dafür an unter anderem wegen
ihrer dichten atmosphäre höheren
temperaturen und größeren durchmessern
die große hoffnung der forschenden
weltweit ist es jetzt mit der hilfe des
james webb weltraumteleskop der nasa
einige dieser planeten ins visier nehmen
zu können der start wurde jetzt nochmal
verschoben am 18 dezember 2021 soll es
endlich soweit sein wow außerirdisches
leben dunkler materie und mehr james
webb weltraumteleskop vor dem start
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht mit dem abo button unter jedem
video und hier also jetzt draufklicken
das kostet nichts und macht schlau und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran